are you guys doing steve how are you
nice to see you again
nice to see you um so i have a lot of
questions and i think i'm going to start
with the most important right up front
uh for each of you what is the
percentage of money
you get from ireland from all the people
that will book trips
after seeing this movie
i'm happy not to participate in the
physical wealth if i get to
have the pleasure of seeing people go
and enjoy the country
yeah uh shanley's is bigger percentage
than mine for sure but
uh but it is very clearly and obviously
a love letter to the to the country
uh in a way that obviously you know it's
based on a play
a play that i happen to see on broadway
uh and and
you know it's the same story but when
you when you add the visual element and
open it up the way that film can
boy does it make ireland look awfully
pretty yeah i wanted to book a trip
this i've been there i still wanted to
book a trip the second the film ended
i'm like i need to go back
like right now you know sorry
that's probably also a testament to
stephen goldblatt it was the cameraman
who also did joe versus the volcano he
just
really killed himself to do the best job
and
i'll be eternally grateful uh another
important question um
what is the amount of guinness that was
drank on set
nobody trying to get us on set but when
they stepped away from it they certainly
did
right take it easy for you right is
there a reason it tastes so much better
in the pub rather than the than the
bottle
i've always wanted to know i think it
just travels
less uh there's less mileage on it i
think it just it comes from
right from the uh from the source
anything from the source is better
right i appreciate you bearing with my
stupid questions um
being serious now for a second um i'm
gonna say john patrick so that way
there's a separation
um how much i love the opening shot and
it like pulls you into this like
fantasy with the music and the visuals
how much as a director do you think
about
the opening shot and the closing shot um
uh a decent amount uh i do
i think about more like the opening of
the story and the closing of the story
uh and then the shout the shots that
would support that
but certainly i wanted to start on the
seacoast
and go inland until we came to where the
story took place
which physically was in uh county mayo
got it um john um the i would imagine
you don't read scripts like this that
often and you're familiar with the
with the play um can you sort of talk
about what
why you wanted to be a part of this and
what the script was like because it
almost has like this magical quality
yeah it's uh i keep referring to it as a
fable um
part of it was uh i have been a fan of
mr shanley's
and i'm i'm very pleased to share uh a
zoom
window with him these days uh uh
but i've been a fan of john's work since
i've been made aware of it back in the
90s 80s whenever it was and um
to get the opportunity to to work on
something like this i saw a doubt in the
theater
i in the in the on broadway i saw when
in fact
a girl i went to high school with was in
the original production of doubt heather
goldenhersch
um so i saw that original production i
saw the original production of outside
mullingar
uh i've just been a fan of his forever
and
to get the opportunity to work with
someone who you're such a fan of
on something that you actually like and
then to make something that you're
intensely proud of that actually is is
delivering a message of of hope
and and positivity in this increasingly
snarky and cynical atmosphere that we
find ourselves in is just a
it's a win-win-win win i think so i was
i was incredibly pleased to be asked to
play with these people
uh john patrick i'm always curious about
the editing process because it's the
final rewrite
what did you what did you learn from any
early screenings
that impacted the finished film well
it's funny you should
ask that because as a result of the
pandemic we only had
one that we could uh and
uh uh it was it was actually still
in an unfinished state and so uh the res
the response was good but we actually
had a long way to go
after that one screening that we were
able to do
before we got it in the final condition
and the last round of editing which was
significant
was really a collaboration
amongst all the producers and me and the
editor
and the stars uh we all just
jumped in and uh argued about
everything uh and then i was the final
arbiter
uh and uh i i at times didn't enjoy
doing it that way
but that was the way it needed to be
done and ultimately led to the film that
i wanted it to be
got it um i i know i got to go but uh
john real quick is uh
what's going on with fletch uh well
we're hoping to start shooting in the
springtime
um in new york city and uh you know
fingers crossed we've got a we've got an
excellent script and an excellent
director attached and we're gonna start
casting soon so
you know it's uh big shoes to fill
obviously but but it's
it's as i've mentioned in previous uh uh
conversations it's a reboot it's not a
remake so we're taking the
going back to the novels and and really
breaking it down but hopefully bringing
bringing what people want to see so
fingers crossed